after their successful eClass sedan and
T model Mercedes is now introducing a
completely reworked coupe a and
Cabriolet to the line the new features
include a powerful yet efficient 4
cylinder engine and an assistance system
called mercedes-benz intelligent drive
but the new models have also retained
the best-loved qualities of a classic
Mercedes
Activa doofuses antagonist driver Robert
satting says Mercedes has paid heed to
the needs of its clientele the e-class
cab really glides over bumpy cobblestone
roads but the chassis is surprisingly
dynamic and agile the suspension and
chassis work well together and they're
complemented by the soft handling but in
terms of comfort what stands out is the
low noise level
with a closed canopy the noise dampening
and waterproof soft top is folded out
and retracted with a push of a button
you
the new assistance features include
systems to prevent accidents at
intersections with crossing vehicles or
pedestrians there is also an active Lane
Keeping assistance and anti-glare
continuous main beam headlights
but who can afford this open-air driving
experience isn't fought like can't you
Mercedes says it's a car for car lovers
no one buys a coupe paid or a Cabriolet
because they need a vehicle to get from
A to B this is an indulgence and there
are many people similar to each class
sedan customers who don't want a sedan
they want something more individual Alto
the proportions are classical for
co-pays and convertibles the elongated
bonnet stretched sides low roofline and
bold tail
luxury and comfort are expected from an
eClass and Mercedes delivers with the
cabriolets interior
named ingen gurgi who says the themes of
efficiency at eco-friendliness were high
priorities for the design team the basic
8200 engine was refitted with entirely
new technology which lowers fuel
consumption and emissions to produce
less than 140 grams of co2 with an
automatic transmission gives the vehicle
Class A efficiency and most importantly
the euro-6 emissions standard it was it
for we tested a Cabriolet with the
second most powerful gasoline engine a
three liter v6 with 245 kilowatt
performance a car powered to 100
kilometers an hour and 5.3 seconds and
continued to accelerate to a speed cap
of 250 kilometers an hour
Mercedes says the e 400 uses 7.6 liters
of fuel per 100 kilometers unfortunately
here in Europe at least the Sun doesn't
always shine but that doesn't seem to
discourage people from buying a
convertible that keeps on can male owner
says there are core markets and
incredibly sunny countries don't play a
major part in Europe it's mainly north
of the Alps in Germany and Britain North
America is a bigger market for
convertibles but their most customers
are in sunny states like Florida and
California they enjoy their Sun out
there in California divinities that's
what Tim Deegan is newest owner
it's one thing to buy a beautiful
convertible but you can't buy beautiful
weather
luckily the soft top on the e-class
Cabriolet proved to be extremely
watertight during our rain tests in
Hamburg and for that extra individual
touch the latest eClass comes in a range
of 11 colours
you
you